well speaking of lying that's happening
right in front of us
it has been more than a month since Paul
Pelosi was attacked in his home on a
Friday night in San Francisco the
assailant we know who he was he was a
hippie nudist called David depape who
we're told with some sort of right-wing
extremist despite being apparently a
black lives matter fan according to NBC
News Paul Pelosi didn't seem afraid of
to Pape even after police arrived in
fact he opened the door for the cops
himself
so what exactly happened in the Pelosi
house that night well there have been a
lot of conspiracy theories about it and
people who've put those forward have
been attacked for it you're crazy so
there's one way to end this debate
immediately and it would be a
constitutional way to end it in fact we
should be demanding it and that's to see
the body cam footage from that night
because these police are public servants
they work for the rest of us they have
no right to hide that
but the police for some reason have
refused to release that body confused we
get body cam footage every day in the
news business but they won't release
this and not only will they not released
that they are intent to not releasing it
into pape's federal court case a judge
has just issued a protective order
Banning the release of sensitive
information in this case and that would
include the body cam footage what is
going on here why are they hiding this
is there a good reason we don't know
Larry Elder ran for governor of
California a state in which he lives and
has lived for many years he joins us
tonight to assess what's going on here
Larry Elder thanks for coming on what do
you think this is why can't we just end
this conversation with the evidence that
we have a right to see
of course we're speculating uh but
somebody does not want somebody to know
what really happened that day I don't
know uh the the NBC reporter who
reported that Pelosi homily opened the
door said he had a hammer in his hand
and calmly walked back that guy got
suspended so we don't really know what's
happening uh we haven't seen any footage
we haven't seen any audio uh we don't
know what the Witnesses are saying uh
maybe Paul Pelosi knew the guy maybe
Nancy Pelosi knew the guy maybe Paul
invited him in we just don't know all I
know is that the official story uh that
we've heard which is very simple this
guy broke into Paul Pelosi's house and
attacked him does not appear to be the
case otherwise why why so secretive why
not tell what's going on why the gag
order I've never seen anything like this
in a criminal case what's infuriating I
mean I should just say I you know I
think Paul Posey is a very nice man I've
met him and I like Paul Pelosi so I
wouldn't I don't I'm not interested in
what Paul Posey was doing there and I
wouldn't be doing this story with you
right now if they hadn't used it to
attack their political opponents oh this
is January 6th the right wing is
attacking the Pelosi I mean they use
this story to attack their political
opponents so we have an absolute right
and obligation to get to the bottom of
it correct
that's right I said something snarky
about it after I made sure that Paul
Pelosi uh was going to recover fully and
I was attacked and other conservatives
were attacked for speculating that
something might have might have gone
wrong or something might have be might
be different than what they're telling
us uh so you're quite right we ought to
know what the story is but we were
attacked it was used to show how
insensitive and cold and callous
conservatives are right before the
midterms yeah they they'll use literally
anything even her husband's attack it's
it's really unbelievable as you well
know having been attacked Larry Elder
great to see you tonight thank you I'm
the I'm the black face the white
supremacy Tucker that's my favorite
attack ever sorry great to see you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight